give us a sense of what the markets were
expecting the fact that they don't need
that Theresa May does not need to
consult Scotland is actually quite
significant yeah absolutely Francine
I've got the judgment here this is the
judgments given handed down by the
Supreme Court just about at nine-thirty
UK's I'm so 40 minutes or so ago we
heard from justice neuburger who's the
president as's of supreme court leading
the eleven judges they found on a ratio
of eight to three there had to be an odd
number of judges so there couldn't be a
tie 823 finding that this does need to
go to Parliament to Parliament does need
to have it say here but as you point out
Francine it doesn't need to have the
explicit consultation of the devolved
administration's in Edinburgh and other
parts of the UK and that's important
because that could have led to a whole
constitutional crisis in the UK so to
some extent markets are as you said back
to where they thought this was going to
go which was that the government has
lost its appeal and this goes to
Parliament yeah and what does this
actually mean I mean it's unlikely that
it will derail Briggs it but it just may
take a little bit longer for article 50
to be triggered yeah absolutely now
becomes a number counting game so there
are 650 seats in the houses of
parliament the Conservative Party has
329 of them can they rely on all of
those MPs to vote with the government
well probably most of them and even of
the other parties many of whom were four
remain originally many of them have come
round to backing bracket because they
don't want to be seen as enemies of the
people so this isn't seen as something
that's going to stop brexit but it is
something could delay it we spoke to an
MP in the last hour who said a bill
could be passed very very quickly but
that's not everybody's view even Jeremy
Corbyn leader the Labour Party is now
saying they will seek amendments various
parties in Parliament will seek
amendments to this bill and that's
what's going to take time there will be
decision making on how many amendments
and for how long they'll be debated and
that's what live us clues as to when we
could finally cr250 triggered
Anna help me here in our global audience
with the power of the Prime Minister is
her power diminished with this ruling
well the government we had from a
government spokesman little bit earlier
on saying that the government is
obviously disappointed but they're
pleased to live in a country that even
the government is subject to the rule of
law and that sir is that the view that
they have taken this morning they'll now
concentrate on enacting what has been
handed down by the judge today her power
has not been diminished in the sense
that at least she doesn't have to ask
for the devolved government approval in
what she's trying to do here if we were
had entered into a situation where
Edinburgh had an effective veto veto of
what London is to raise constitutional
questions and reduced her power here she
has to admit that she has lost this
appeal she was arguing she had some kind
of prerogative power from the days when
we used to have the crown deciding these
things she doesn't have that according
to these eight to three judges